Poles came to mourn the man who led their
city for two decades.
Pavel Adam-OH-vitch, a husband and father,
was one of the country's progressive voices.
EU council president Donald Tusk flew to Gdansk,
his hometown, to honor his friend:
I want to promise you today, dear Pawel, on
behalf of all of us – Gdansk residents,
Poles and Europeans – that for you and for
all of us we will defend our Gdansk, our Poland
and our Europe against hatred and contempt,
we promise you this.
Farewell Pawel.
Many people knew him personally:
For me it's terrible news, especially since
we went to grade school together, just over
there.
I thought he would survive.
I'm physically devastated.
I'm very sad because I saw the mayor very
often.
On Sunday, PA-vel Adam-OH-vitch was praising
a fundraising effort for children in need.
As the mayor looked out at thousands of people,
a man lunged at him with a knife.
The attacker then remained on stage, shouting
that he blamed the mayor's former party for
wrongfully imprisoning him.
Then he was tackled to the ground.
Prosecutors are charging the 27-year-old suspect
with murder.
Just before his death, Adamowicz called Gdansk
the
most wonderful city in
the world.
A
lasting message to the people he served.